agrawal  here he is commenting on free speech and  misinformation and if this doesn't send  chills down your spine especially  considering these bumping elbows with  the elite who are in control of your  taxes and your guns it should  somebody in the audience is also  pointing out that you're trying to  combat this information you also want to  protect free speech as a core value and  also in the us as the first amendment  how do you balance those two  our role is not to  be bound by the first amendment to focus  less on thinking about free speech but  thinking about how the times have  changed ah most people can speak where  our role is particularly emphasized is  who can be heard deciding who is going  to get heard or which voices should get  more attention  is just as fraught a question as which  voices should be suppressed  that's exactly right